well so thanks welcome everyone first of
all to the second online meeting that we
organize here and connect the data
London even though you know London is a
kind of relative term because none of us
five people who are so it mean this
panel today is actually based in London
well this is the upside of having a
visual pun its face-to-face one which
was the original idea behind this panel
so just a sir with a little bit with the
world so the panel we're having today is
about 2020 vision for the Semantic Web
and it all started basically again very
slowly so a thread Twitter thread and
exchange between us that we were
planning to actually meet in Athens and
have this bundle of the real live
discussion well since we're not going to
be able to do that we thought we might
as well do that we can see how the
discussion even remotely so this is the
the idea behind today's panel so with
that I'm going to switch hand over
basically to go to David who will be
moderating I only have one last thing to
say before that which is to thank our
sponsors today Brimfield computers and
bringing computers are the makers of
several which is a software intelligence
tool that analyzes and investigates
running applications serval is a Python
agent and a web interface aiming to
understand existing information systems
and legacy applications and again many
thanks for for sponsoring today and
without further ado David it's on to you
and happy moderating and let's all enjoy
the conversation thank you very much
like a quick introduction basically both
to the subject matter and to our subject
experts today and in no particular order
the experts are George are not the Audis
who has written about extensively about
the Semantic Web he knows about graphs
and has extensive experience in the
online world we have Theodora pankova
and she has written a book about how on
the text how our text changes in the
Semantic Web how
all these links and changes in the way
we communicate we have panels Alex
applause with part of on the text and
he's an expert in ontology building and
for both of you
sorry yes I'm not part of the text sorry
I'm sorry mark there is there is some
text it's called and is an expert in
ontology building and correcting this
right and and for those of you who are
not familiar with ontology which is a
slightly philosophical subject which has
real-world applications it's the way
that things are classified in the web
and how we actually put things together
and finally we have professor professor
I made chef with us who is an expert in
quite a wide variety of things for
enterpreneurship to artificial
intelligence in the Semantic Web and how
those technologies come together today
subject which is essentially what is
happening in a Semantic Web it's a state
of play in many ways and we're looking
at 20 years of progress and also we're
trying to find out what the next step
will be so we've got some questions to
start off with which will help guide the
discussion and any of you attending now
if you have any kind of questions as we
progress if you ask them of the panel I
will try to bring them in and I'll try
to give you answers in real time so
let's begin with the first question and
the first question is we have 20 years
of semantic web building in the 21st
century it's come from the limelight to
obscurity and back again has this taught
us anything about how the Semantic Web
works and does it give us perhaps an
inkling of how it's going to progress
and we'll take this question perhaps to
George if George that's ok with you
George it's fine actually I can use the
opportunity to say a little bit about
how I got hooked let's say on the
Semantic Web and even though I'm not I'm
not one of the few of the people that
actually because it started like a myth
is for example I was a kind of early
adopter let's say and the thing that
attracted me back then
actually if you are the people in the
audience who may be familiar with what
we call the Semantic Web cake or stack
it's a kind of layer of functionalities
that when the Semantic Web first was
prescribed let's say I was supposed to
show the different layers of
functionality and how it's going to work
and you have things such as I arise at
the bottom so standards that help you
locate things basically and then you
kind of build on that actually that so
the part of the stack that got attracted
me the most was one that hasn't yet been
implemented actually and that was the
agent the agent part so I was much very
much attracted by the ability to have
different agents in my mind I could see
them but they're not kind of acting on
behalf of the user
who'd be able to get the Preferences of
the user there the cognitive domain of
the fusion and the underlying layers
would be the ones that kind of encoded
this knowledge and would be able to ask
an ago she ate and do different perform
different actions on behalf of the user
in the disability way it was ambitious
but then it's it's still ambitious today
which is why it hasn't been fully fully
realized but you know this is this is
the part that attracted me so to go back
to the question what going back to you
know from from the limelight to
obscurity and but again hostile to us I
would say Cass told us a number of
things and I basically start with the
ambition and when you have something
like this which has been initiated and
[Music]
advocated by someone like Sir Tim
berners-lee who's credited with the
invention of the web and to a large
extent he has been behind the semantic
world as well well ambition you know
lack of ambition is definitely not not
an issue maybe actually it's it was a
bit on the other side of the spectrum so
a bit over-ambitious let's say looking
at least today you know from from the
standpoint of almost 20 years after it
was you know this vision was way
way ahead of its time so this is one
thing you know when we talk about
semantic web failing or succeeding or
whatever today we have the luxury of
doing that almost two decades after it
was initially conceived so we have to
you know have to put that into
perspective and even though you know
some some parts of the stack didn't were
not fully realized on this part other
parts where and are and are very very
useful today and people actually use
them everyday even though they may not
realize it for a static this is actually
a good thing not realizing that you that
you're using it so in that sense it's
it's a success so I would say that you
know this is another take away if you
make the technology go in the background
so that people don't explicitly have to
use it then I would call it a success
you know it brings better adoption but I
think I've already said enough I mean I
could go on and on but I'm sorry the
other panels we have something to say
that's it that's great thank you very
much for that perspective and I think
it's sort of covered a lot of things in
a fairly spherical way so it gives a
nice grounding to where we are right now
so let's um we mentioned that the
Semantic Web began fairly strongly as an
idea then you fade into obscurity and
then it came back now
the question that arises from this is
that just like perceptual rebranding and
some pragmatism those required or do we
need something deeper here and perhaps
some Ghidorah would like to try this yes
sir I just wanna I have something to say
about fade into obscurity
I've never faded into already it it was
I mean also I am thinking about why do
we say that it's 20 years around as many
we're just reminding about a 94
presentation Tim berners-lee in Geneva
where he talks about the way content
needs to be described for machines so
that what the web is not flat for them
and we mean the machines so yeah yeah
bathing into obscurity of something that
is thirty years old he's a bit I don't
know I don't like the framing the
breathing I would go with what an
exciting thing the web is and the web
will never be done the same is with the
Semantic Web it will never be done
it's a way forward and that's
professorship won't the beautiful
article about building knowledge graphs
it takes a hundred ten for a thousand
and to build a knowledge graph so the
Semantic Web would take a lot more and a
lot more coherence and debate and
finally I didn't answer your question
David what was your question well the
question was and I will also ask commit
to add to this the question was that
perceptually in order for us to begin to
actually thinking about the Semantic Web
in a broader context with a large a much
larger base of people was all that was
required a case of rebranding it so that
becomes perhaps more accessible no I
don't think it was Metro its matter of
rebranding it so I was in this area I
felt at my first paper I can actually
show that had the same concern schematic
web was 1994 published in C I came
conference which had multiple
oncologists and use of introduced to
access data he twitches databases that
was the paper in that was 1994
unfortunately I use the word semantic
information proclaiming to call whatever
I meant the word Semantic Web was far I
guess catchy and it came from timber
asleep now following reason why
a Semantic Web did not succeed a whole
lot as much as people thought was that
they're too much first of all they were
sweating where was two communities so
one was people who went for logic and
who won for completeness of knowledge
and he went for reasoning and other
where people who already understood the
value of the knowledge and use of
knowledge in applications processing
search and things of that nature 1999 I
started my first company in my second
company which was the Semantic Web
company the first time interior company
and we got the first pattern with
Semantic Web in the title in 2001 5 1 it
was filing year 2000 so cement Semantic
Web for semantic search browsing
personalization and advertisement that
was what the patent was about and the
fundamental thing about the pattern was
that I choose the more practical you
know route compared to the year 2000
paper but Tim berners-lee handler paper
which talked about agents and logic and
this is making this was about creating a
very large we used to call world model
or ontology or federal is same as
knowledge graph in the sense that it was
much more practical representational
knowledge that did not seek the
completeness that did not require logic
another foundation the reasoning being
this very practical aspect how many
people are not logical like to use logic
after they graduate and our peoples are
taught graph and it's such data
structure and they can use those such
data structure after they graduate and
the second thing is that being able to
create knowledge that is not perfectly
accurate but is large enough to catch
the laughing as much bigger value then
but very hard to get a small knowledge
base that is very consistent and
complete and you know you can have
proved theoretical travel cavities so
we've been the search engine my company
the company I founded still survives
except that because of the internal
bubble burst we have to become
ethical market focus so it only works in
the financial services market then what
happened is that in the first five to
ten years of semantic web a lot of
things happen with owl and description
logic and many things like that
there's nothing that has really
succeeded from that line of work
all right little there is succeeded just
for the I'm sorry to interrupt for the
benefit of the people who may not be
familiar with that owl is Prabha is a
language which is used to essentially
code specific aspects of it
yeah that knowledge to the personal
knowledge I always used the web ontology
language is to represent that but there
was a lighter version of that that also
Tim berners-lee read not is not in year
2000 but in around you know three four
five years later and he coin oh he
really got into this link data that
ended up being a lot more practical
aspect of the Semantic Web the Hydra
server very well now like rather giving
a very long answer I'll give very simple
and straight answer why is what we want
to call semantic way back many people
will not give semantic web a credit for
what is happening in the knowledge graph
in it work now that if you like to take
a trade because I had pattern greens or
somatic web that had knowledge graph and
others also work on that the reason is
that people who recognize a fundamental
value of knowledge in year 2012 they you
know this deep learning happened before
that turns machine learn and much of the
AI was all about machine learning and
deep learning a little bit about NLP now
they have reached the limit much of it
in NLP and machine learning and deep
learning and everybody's recognized that
knowledge is power edit ease whatever
investment you need to make is what
making the investment because Google
prude it in year 2012
they started with meta where freebase
and clearly this knowledge graph and
since then 2013 in semantic search you
can't think of search without knowledge
graph so the value was so overwhelming
that whatever
the investment to create knowledge graph
is what it and that now is really a
sticker
so every company basically has their own
knowledge graph or their licensing
knowledge graph on somebody else and
they feel that the investment they're
making it is still well worth it I have
a student I'll end up with just one
observation I was told who went to
Amazon last year because of mrs. dorset
around me I can't find a single project
that does not use knowledge graph so so
I and
if to the extent the Semantic Web can
take credit for noise but graph means
ecosystem and I'm happy to describe that
later on okay at xx and this is really
succeeded now perfect perfect it's
really good yes yes you can
I think what I'm it's very correct but
the like to clarify something at least
my perspective definitely yes and
knowledge graph what we're witnessing
right now this year right here is the
coming back not of the Shimon develop in
my opinion but coming back this the
power of symbolic knowledge and
reasoning the Semantic Web started in
1994 but that is nice before in the 80s
they were already the idea of semantic
networks of expert systems but then etc
so ultimate inaccurate to say that it's
the Semantic Web that brought this into
existence was a model of trying to do is
bring that into a large scale right by
creating some standards based on which
anyone can do that at the web level and
to some extent what we're witnessing
right now is the larger scale of
knowledge graph so instead of having a
small ontology or a small knowledge
graph of the couple hundred of entities
we have millions of entities the other
hand I am I really doubt well there we
have it semantic interoperability so
whether for instance the knowledge graph
of I don't know a compound like Thomson
Reuters is really semantic interoperable
with
the knowledge graph JP Morgan for
instance if the event recycling
knowledge is still trapped in silos
although silos uh perhaps elute
enterprise knowledge graph that's why
the term enterprise noise graph is
coming to be yes listen so I think we're
listening now at least the way I have
seen it in in in the other price level
because this is the where I mostly wore
is that indeed because of the
limitations that exist in the machine
learning approach etc we still need
domain knowledge within symbolic
knowledge and reasoning to enhance this
so companies now have incentive
additional incentives to do that because
they have realized that you know we have
all this amount of data
it's nothing have to put them in a data
link and we need the semantic layer we
tell us what these are about
right and this is partial still on
can you see me yeah yes certainly we
have so this is partially the revision
regime at the web but also the same and
we've got other aspect not very forward
now so it would be an example the MIDI
web dissol about the open world
assumption I don't think many companies
would would like to to use that's why
subtle came arouse the last couple of
years right or the Semantic Web is about
in the leaking data right there is this
mantra that Intel evening is good you
know we need to link data personally I'm
very careful what I link my knowledge
graph right because it's not that simple
it's not that simple to ensure that just
by using image WebP and I think the
little data you ensure that everything
is nicely written correct right that's
my five cents
David come Afghanistan yeah we can hear
you today we yep just to add to what
panel said and actually I think
something that none of us highlighted
explicitly up to up to this point which
sees the connection let's say between
oldest crafts and cement and the
Semantic Web because I guess most people
not necessarily in this audience because
it probably attracted the kind of
special nice possibly but most people
these days are quite familiar with Nolan
scrubs while they're not necessarily
equally familiar with the Semantic Web
well knowledge graphs are entirely based
on cement not just a semantic web
approach but in many many cases on the
semantic web technology as well even
though you know this is not an absolute
requirements it's it's basically the
same thing this is why we talked about
rebranding
yeah and partly that is to some extent
is true because for example one very
widely used knowledge is key murat orb
oh and there is kind of some aspect of
what we you know standardization work
that we had done that gets reflected
there and and you know one very common
knowledge graph that almost everybody
uses his knowledge graph extracted from
wikipedia the dbpedia and again there is
use of what a pie for a piece was
implemented dbpedia so in the period
tool so that that also used Semantic Web
technologies I mean when I ask you
something do you know any any company
that uses Wikipedia for for-profit I
mean your way that to self clients and
trusts the DPD arts quality and all
aspects right because it doesn't really
have
so I'm wondering yeah all the such
companies you know I just in fact saw
somebody who came up with the knowledge
panel and the knowledge panel it's the
first version of the honest press all
based on Wikipedia so so in the search
context they are really monetizing
Wikipedia in whatever they are doing
they basically anything that is consumer
facing there is extensive use of
Wikipedia hiding media when it is
business or you know customer facing
then they they build their own stuff
okay David are you connection problems
oh okay then I think you want to Georgia
take the next question
yep since actually Theodora we were
supposed you were supposed to be given
that one and somehow we lost we lost the
flow in the process so your point on
whether you know the semantic weight
should be framed as having gone to
obscurity was was well taken but but I
think if he may actually wanted to to
address the question that that was
framed by David which is what's going
back and forth let's say not let's not
use the word obscurity since you've made
the point of that but basically what
happened with uh sematic what was that
you know when it was first introduced
let's say there were high hopes about it
then but actually I did I would I would
argue that you know this basically
happens with pretty much all technology
when it's first introduced you know it
means everything to everyone and you
know everybody expects it to be the
greatest thing and to do that you know
immediately within the next couple of
years and of course when this doesn't
happen there's this kind of you know
disappointment let's say so for the why
this happened to the Semantic Web then
it's also the the additional aspect that
it
has in some ways and for some reason
being as being associated connected to
having an academic approach whatever
that may be we're going to touch on that
further on but you know for for very
real reasons the Semantic Web has kind
of you know lost its appeal and so now
we're saying that it's making a comeback
under a different name you know James
the reference to you know no lets graphs
and all these this kind of terminology
so the question to you the after this
very long introduction is so what do you
think that this course has has told us
if anything you know from going from
being the next best thing to
disillusionment and now actually seeing
some some actual real world adoption
thanks for the question I was thinking
about this about the high hopes about
the Semantic Web and maybe because I'm
not into the gist of it white pants is
and I totally agree with all of the
points he made that who for example who
uses dbpedia I think the the argument
there and thumbs please correct me if
I'm wrong is that the day there is dirty
not dirty but you need to clean the data
and work a lot on the data indeed will
be near as no use it as a as part of
your knowledge graph is this for you man
yeah so the quality in general is that
it's not only accuracy its accuracy plus
context plus what it is useful for so
it's not only when it comes to a
knowledge graph for a particular purpose
it's not only what it contains initially
but how it is governed that how it is
evolved right the one thing that you can
control it you want to control when you
use a knowledge graph is its evolution
you want to go towards the direction you
want so if dbpedia has a hundred domains
who decides what domain will be covered
next or that's important it is very
important and I use it to make my point
that again it's a
effort and it gets effort and yes it
takes money and yes it's not something
busy the Semantic Web and about the high
hopes I can't think of any higher
purpose than mapping knowledge in a
machine-readable way so whatever we do
we are to bump into challenges the
challenges of the knowledge soup and the
challenges of learn to think together
this is regarding the the question about
academia and business I'm facing the
same challenge with academic literature
sometimes not very but not being very
coherent with business practices but why
don't we just leave this as it is like
academia for thinking and business for
trying to translate these think this
thinking into actions of course there
there will be discrepancy discrepancies
and then let's handle them in in the eye
Institute which I have now I we do a lot
of real-world projects in medicine and
public health in many other things so I
don't think that I mean then it's not a
straight some of us are as practical as
industry maybe and you know I currently
have three companies that use knowledge
graph one way or other that I found it
so there is no such you know strong
distinction one point I would like to
make you said look the knowledge that is
created by collective work as in
Wikipedia or as a schema or odd is
essentially free because everybody chips
in a little bit it has its limit
but because it is free it is going to be
widely using it is being widely used and
then there is a need for specialized
knowledge you need to go deep into a
subject area that a public knowledge
source like Wikipedia won't be
appropriate we were developing a
knowledge graph for human performance
and cognition well that's a specialized
field and there is only so much about
human performance in cognition dopa mind
and other chemicals and how brain works
on those car things that is in Wikipedia
so then we have to go and really invest
our own time and effort to develop and
flush out to you the details and depth
that is necessary to use but we actually
use skeletal information just to get
started from Wikipedia and then we went
on to mine knowledge from very
specifically treasure in that domain to
create that highly specialized knowledge
graph so I think both of them can work
together there isn't any that doesn't
have to be very strict deadlines I know
distinction is what I think it can if it
has to do much better than it has the
way the past is to give us the train
manpower
you know people who are trained to
deliver systems a long semantic web and
our knowledge graph means technologies
there are too many people being trained
for machine learning to queue for
knowledge centric ecosystem if I may add
to that emitter that was exactly what I
wanted to say I mean as far as the the
tension let's say between academia and
industry ghosts so I mean this this or
anyway this exists anyway regardless of
the domain but in this case here we're
talking about a very specific domain a
Theodora pointed out earlier we're
talking about capturing know--let's and
this mix in my opinion makes the tension
even more pronounced because academia is
specifically trained and geared towards
doing
without and you know this kind of
analytical thinking and abstraction and
so on and so forth
business on the industry on the other
hand has a totally different approach
more practical goal-oriented
you know and in many times that also
means cutting corners and not actually
investing enough in seeing the bigger
picture and actually documenting that so
this is already a kind of tension in
terms of approach and if you add to that
the very specific issues that have to do
with software develop and so this is
something that you know admittedly
industry is much better at for a number
of reasons I mean it's not actually the
the main job of academics is not to
build software so they haven't many of
them you know haven't had like you know
proper training in that and haven't
actually had the experience of building
you know industrial-strength software
systems and and so on plus you know in
academia there is a high level so people
don't stay long enough in a certain
position to be able you know to to
develop the skills and there's no actual
business model in academia this also has
a lot to do you know if you're building
a social product you need to think about
you know things such as how is it going
to appeal to users how am I going to
market it and all of these things this
these things are not in the mindset of
academics and you know rightfully so I
would say you know it's not their job to
do these things but for a long time the
software development that related to the
Semantic Web was more or less in the
hands of academics for you know people
who are directly out of academia and
that had a very real I would say
affecting the quality of the software
and so many people who got exposed to
the software that came out you know of
the Semantic Web camp would say around
that time got disillusioned and you know
mad mad some of them may have returned
others just stayed with that impression
oh you know it's the software just
doesn't work and they just walk away
hopefully they they made a return by now
because by now there's a ton of vendors
that use similar technology and they do
a very very
job but you know it's kind of you have
to change that that preconception in
order to we have a couple of questions
which perhaps should be addressed from
the chart one of them is the first one
is practical it's from Mohammed and he's
asking how does gtp are applied to data
management especially knowledge graphs
somebody would like to pick this up
[Music]
Amit yes in the knowledge graph it
defense aa depends on how you define it
I'll give you an example we develop an
application that was about electronic
medical records and we had knowledge
graph about how drugs you know what the
medical drugs and in that drug to drug
interaction for example was model as
rules to the alternative concept now
similarly gdpr can be translated you
know can be represented as constraints
and rules that may you know that will
constrain on the utilization of the data
so if the data is personally
identifiable data then you're going to
do something or the other
and for that you can think of it as a
enhancement of knowledge graph or a
layer or knowledge graph to capture
these kind of rules and regulations that
can tend constraint on the use of the
detail of this side when describing Amit
does this reflect a little bit on what
panels described earlier when he said it
is a lot of company knowledge graphs
which are essentially siloed and there's
no internet interoperability in the data
from one knowledge graph to another for
various reasons know allows physical
thing is that the composition of
knowledge graph you know when you talk
about knowledge you can limit it to
see the facts that's the core of Raja
but you can also incorporate in that the
actions that we can take using that
knowledge we actions of creating the
knowledge and storing something leader
those can be modeled and can be called
as part of knowledge graph and hence the
answer to Hammad will be that some of
the companies could choose to codify
gdpr as part of their knowledge graph
representation extensive knowledge graph
and has consistently deployed deployed
better the other way and keep the GDP
are you don't within the logic of a
replication which can be more costly and
more hidden and so I think it's you can
you can make it more explicit and put it
as part of knowledge graph rather than
leave it to just the applications to
implement GDP a that right application
that use knowledge graph and so that was
my answer to each question right
honestly so I will give the example of
text journal so what we do is that our
notice graph is about occupations and
skills for the labor market and much of
the data that we use in order to process
note but also to construct the knowledge
graph from our CVS right curriculum with
us and vacancies so CV is a really
sensitive right if a company gives us a
fist process we need to be really
careful what to do with them right
because they're sensitive personal data
so obviously the first level in the
knowledge graph about gtp are is if
you're going to explicitly present
persons write medical records this can
be or I don't know financial
transactions of individual people right
you need to ensure that you have there
okay that's that's the explicit level
right that you talked about David Tamara
learn and it says you know let's panel
that they've done Berlin I don't know
he's a serial killer right for instance
with not true the second the second
level which is a more gray area is when
use this data to derive facts for the
population right to say for example that
you look we analyzed one millions
degrees and one with in vacancies and we
found that this particular age group is
more skilled in I don't know in deep
learning this is is that something that
we are Tatars
but it can be that biases out if you
have to really to really be careful for
that not to be should right but rather
not to any hard not to create bias in
your knowledge browser so we may be
thinking that you know it's machine
learning and deep learning that our
biases or certain biases but also the
explicit knowledge that we put in our
graphs right okay and there's an
observation more than I've more an
observation and a question that's
appeared in the chat and it's from Jose
and he's saying the idea of the Semantic
Web is a worldwide distributed mutual
knowledge base he still to be realized
nothing panels this is what you were
alluding to when he said that there can
be implicit bias there Jose says it is a
continuous endless battle between
proponents of an open world which is
more beneficial to society on longer
term versus proponents of market
oriented world gardens that have been
successful in the last ten years like
Facebook Google etc and says this poses
a challenge which we haven't yet met I
suppose would anybody like to comment on
this yes yes I know so inherently Tim
berners-lee whom we do pretty credit for
this term is you know very much a into
open openness and you know creating
products that are good for Humanity and
let
in everybody should contribute to a
common thing and and benefit from that
what says as Josh mentioned the wall
gardens that companies wanted to do and
that's where for example Facebook is on
the web but is not consistent with the
web's vision now but i but i think i
mean i use semantic principles and you
know the complete right sign in 1999 we
had commercial products and services web
search engine in 2000 2000 in no time
frame well it was a commercial company
and I did not make knowledge graph that
we build in the company public so you
know the cost of building this knowledge
graph is very quite significant in a we
had figured out amazing way missing a
lot of automation but by and large I was
giving a keynote to my conference of
knowledge graph there were 600 people in
audience and the guy who introduced me
was from Google knowledge graph you know
what you're just transitioning out from
goal lines graph but he told me that
they have 10,000 people contributing to
the knowledge graph amazing the amount
of investment in and it also tells you
clearly that so much of the knowledge
graph work is manual and that it also
the same way so much of the work cream
or involving removing hateful content is
manual during right so when I said that
it's not and they still but it's not
about when I say that the linking is not
always good is that this is it's not
that you can behave you corporations
from the one hand and the hippies on the
other it's about the fact that there are
both technological and human reasons why
knowledge agent is not beautiful
knowledge is not neutral we have to
accept it
it's quite neutral to talk about where
was a person born in etc but when we
start thinking about politics we talk
about history when we start talking
about all these things right very
difficult to create an objective neutral
truth about all these things right now
vaguely you have uncertainty you have
immunity have context specificity and
one big limitation of the Semantic Web
which after 20 or something years hasn't
really been realized is the person we're
still taking booyah we still have more
that talks about true and false right
and and even though there have been some
efforts to try to reason with uncertain
and vague information it hasn't yet so I
cannot work with just boolean or if I
have to work on it with boolean and it
to somehow constrained the potential
range of opinions because much of the
noleads whether we like it or not are
opinions or subjective opinions on that
score Pano's has a question which is
right into your expertise
it's from Anna hunter and she's say
asking how do you connect ontology to
knowledge graph in domain specific use
cases with complex and unstructured data
how much ontology is important so
there's two questions there really the
famous question what is the difference
between neurology and in this graph say
the borders Harry and then there is a
specific reason for that so if we take
the same month the web is a MIDI web
talked about with all especially try to
split the world between classes and
individuals right and then one idea was
that you know individuals of the data
and classes are the conceptual lab but
in the end this class of individuals are
all right so if if identified
take the concept that a scientist I can
make it a class and all of us are
instances of this or I can make it a
concept and I can say that it's the
profession of all of us right I make it
I can make it sorry I can make it an
individual concept so really the
question is about so what what is your
ontology it can be my knowledge graph
and vice versa yeah it's really it
really depends on the representation my
view is that what you have is a entities
in their structured data you have
strings you have you have terms if you
life by giving when will you build
semantics you have to give meaning to
terms and give meaning to terms by by
transforming them into concepts right so
you have the concept that then back how
many minutes will it have 20 minutes you
need to have 20 concepts and started
relating the concepts right now how much
meaning you need to give it depends a
lot on what or how how big is your
domain how big is your ambiguity and the
more ambiguous it is the more background
knowledge you need it depends also on
the methods you use right it's not a
clear-cut question excellent the thing I
think that's that actually showcases the
difficulties of other people having in a
commercial in a commercial sort of
respect in terms of getting their
websites and their domains accurately
represented and accurately appear in
search queries in search and sort of
they're in a contextual sort of an
environment which reflects exactly what
they do it I think that actually shows
why and thank you very much for
mentioning this is brilliant how about
the question of how do you connect
ontology to a knowledge graph I mean how
would you do that in a practical term
and I think again this is probably the
main specific one but if you saw your
general answer you know and I gave a
link to the paper that we wrote which
kind of we try to make the distinction
or or connect the terms ontology and
knowledge knowledge graph and
recently one of the three Turing Award
winner also use the word world model
which also we had used it in our patent
point is that it is my view is that the
for any user there isn't you can use the
word Ultron G or knowledge graph
generally speaking knowledge graph
representations are not as reaches what
we used to call our ology generally
speaking all technologies were largely
model deposited in our language or
something of the Third Kind description
logic and they'll be speaking ultra
rodney's represent ontological
commitment very fundamental aspect of
ultros the definition itself the two
aspects of ontology it seems that also
you commit to insert means there is a by
by the community or by being by those
who are going to use this ontology there
is a fundamental aspects of otology
engineering work and in the case of
knowledge graph people don't care about
it or if you know that and that is where
it comes the use knowledge graph you
know within an enterprise in Walt Garvey
and you're not looking for seeking the I
know you are saying this is you know my
company's view on it and this see or
this is how industry will use what I
define and take-it-or-leave-it kind of
thing so you have market power and
you're exercising that to exploit that
but there's no effort so in general it
is a there's a prat in oh if you can
make a sense where you want to call it
ultra G or knowledge graph but at the
fundamental level but first for both of
them is a saying that you infuse
knowledge in understanding the Rinka in
processing of the data in associating
meaning with the data in gaining
insights from the data knowledge just
the same way that in deep learning new
networks statistical processing pattern
decree no recognition plays a
fundamental role what they do
knowledge plays fundamental role in
making connection between whatever you
have in the data with what we
to call conceptual representation and
then make connections so the moment I
say that this this thing string is David
a melon and that he has this company
that is this concept along with that I
immediately get the knowledge that he
works for this company he has made this
contribution so on so forth that power
you get you get it whether you colleague
on Rajee or you can acknowledge graphs
and the minimum of both of them the most
important construct is relationship
label label relationship so named
earlier there was a very interesting a
point been made about label property
graph versus nod EF the common part is
still relationship and a neighbor
relationship and there's some more that
people have not found that valuable the
the practical world and Industry who
built Enterprise in the knowledge graph
have not found all the representation
and challenges of RDF to be worth the
effort and that's basically why it has
come down to that you get 90% of things
with lower cost by using labor graph so
my own company I I had research papers
in 1990s that used knowledge graph 1996
and 1998 but when I implemented
you know our knowledge graph we did not
use RDF as a whole we use RDF light
right
okay and and on that score yes Pano's by
all means agree on that what I said
indeed ontology is a commitment right
but I'd like again to say that like if
we take the VP Dia for instance what is
the ontology of dbpedia so maybe there
has some classes like 300 or for campus
classes right but this is not the
ontology so every time in dbpedia
defines a concept for example data
scientists which is not necessarily a
class but pay it's a resource we still
have a commitment there so that we all
agree what a data scientist is so it's
not that the what I won't clarify is
that people should not think that there
is a distinction between
ontologies just the classes in the
axioms
you know and all the rest of the
entities do not have ontological
commitments the whole goal is for this
to have also commitments and this is
something we need to address a second
thing about question about labels
property graphs and RDF indeed the main
difference between these two for me is
the predefined semantics so the thing is
that for instance RDF gives me a
constant is called a DFS subclass for
instance right which has a meaning that
we all agree what it is whereas in I
cannot I can also implement that in in
my new for J in my in my property graph
is just that it's not going to be a
standard right so that I think is what
makes one framework more semantic than
the other as long as this commitment is
respected because in this commitment is
not respected and people abuse the
constructs of RDF or of all then we're
not getting so much interoperability and
this is happening and one example one
basic example is they all say must try
to see how many mistakes are there great
and I think that's really cool and
there's one more question which is
coming and perhaps Teodoro is best
suited for this and there is written
about the way that text morphs across
the web in terms of definitions and how
we use it and the question is is text
constantly mutating or can we somehow
fix it as we go across the web in terms
of definitions dildora know we can fix
it we're not in the business of fixing
meaning but rather of dancing with it so
much like the Semantic Web which promise
that you'll see the way I do on the back
of that calm very quickly Theodora is if
we if meaning is constantly in flux then
how do we communicate across different
cultures or different contexts
so this is a pretty deep question I'll
give you a simple example the person is
married to person person is matrix and B
and the two are in really you know
marriage relationship then there is a
divorce the two persons are no longer
married and person a marries person C
that's another person with relationship
in between there is no relationship with
any other person of the same kind and so
on so forth so one of the many aspects
of this transient relationship is the
fact that things evolve but this is just
one of many aspects of the evolution and
it changes the meaning and there's more
that you can think about it's a pretty
challenging and deep subject the meaning
of though it was even more difficult so
for example you would expect that the
relationship of marriage has a more
reliable and long-term relationship but
as we know in our lifetime in lasts for
20 years no change right what used to be
called marriage or you know on between
man and woman is no longer a restriction
and in fact in many countries it's
legally accepted as such so all the you
know the meaning both the schema level
can change as in the example like said
of the marriage and the meaning of the
instance level can change as in the
example of person being married to
person and divorced and other things can
change also and there are more of those
things we probably don't have time for
okay thank you very much and we are
indeed running out of time now despite
the fact that all of you tried to put in
as much depth to everything I think
we've barely scratched the conversation
here in the conversation it was probably
enough
materials some of the questions and
certainly in your knowledge to go on for
several hours on this
however we are getting near the end of
this session so George would you like to
sort of um have our final word here yes
well first of all yes as you said David
we only just scratched the surface and
you know we would actually go on for a
long time but it's it's a complex it's a
complex topic so maybe we can we can
have a part two at some point and
hopefully with better sound on my side I
apologize for that there was nothing in
the plan but you know how live shows are
sometimes so anyway since we have to
prepare for the next session I would
just like to thank all of you for for
your insights and well hopefully we can
continue the conversation next time
thank you thank you very much to all
those who participated in with our
questions yes thank you very much so
take care